-The Biden administration moved
to oust several Trump holdovers,
including Sean Spicer and
Kellyanne Conway,
from military academy boards,
while the former president
himself
issued a statement claiming
that -- let me see
if I have this right --
Confederate General
Robert E. Lee
would have won
the war in Afghanistan.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
There's a simple truth
about our history
which has somehow been muddied
through decades
of self-serving revisionism by
racists and apologists
for white supremacy,
and that is that the Confederacy
was a movement of anti-American
traders and slavers
who tried to destroy
this country.
I can't believe that even
has to be said,
but, apparently, it does.
There are people out there
who don't even know
what the Civil War was about,
like, for example, the former
president of the United States.
-People don't realize, you know,
the Civil War, um...
-Yeah.
-...you think about it, why?
People don't ask that question,
but why was there the Civil War?
Why could that one
not have been worked out?
-Yeah, people
don't ask the question
"Why was there the Civil War?"
just like we don't ask,
"How many sides
does a triangle have?"
or, "Is a snake a reptile?"
Because we learned all that
[Bleep] in grade school.
At least, those of us
who weren't following our dad
to construction sites
to watch him yell at immigrants.
What do you mean
"don't ask that question"?
It was a white-supremacist
rebellion
against the government,
not a fight between
my wife and her sister.
"What are they mad about?"
"Don't ask."
I know Donald Trump doesn't live
in our reality,
but it's still interesting
to find out stuff
about his reality.
Like, I guess, in his reality,
the local libraries only have
one book on the Civil War,
called, "What the Heck Was All
This Nonsense About?"
Also, I like
that he wants to know
why could that not have
been worked out?
Yeah, why couldn't you get
the top Union generals
and the to Confederate generals
in a room,
stick Andy Cohen in the middle,
and talk it down
over some skinny margs?
I mean, seriously,
you don't have to be
the chair of a college
history department
to know that the Confederacy
and its leaders were evil.
Hell, you just had to have
a substitute teacher
in high school
who forgot the lesson plan
and played "Glory" on laser disc
while he put his head down
on the desk and took a nap.
Yeah, sure, sure,
all the other kids
secretly passed notes
and played games,
but me, I was watching.
Total "Glory" stand.
You might say
that for one magical year,
I was deep in the "Glory" hole.
I'd prefer if you didn't!
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Freeman, Washington,
Braugher, yes, please.
Plus, I like to pretend that
Matthew Broderick's character
was just like Ferris Bueller,
and before every battle,
the general would say,
"Colonel Shaw?
Colonel Shaw?"
Unfortunately, part of the
reason we have to keep stating
that obvious fact about
the evil of the Confederacy
and the reality of
the Civil War is
that shortly after
the end of the war,
in Reconstruction,
a racist revisionist
lost-cause movement rose up
to cast the leaders
of the Confederacy
as a noble gentleman,
instead of the defeated traders
and white supremacists
that they were.
Nowadays, lots of us don't even
learn about Reconstruction
and the post-Civil War period
in history class.
I mean, I can't believe
people are worried
about critical race theory
when my history textbook
jumped from the Civil War
to the Great Depression,
and in between, there was one
page about William Howard Taft
getting stuck in a bathtub.
Now, I know
that story is apocryphal,
and that it didn't even start
to spread until decades later,
but it's also super funny to me
that someone
went out of their way
to make it up and spread it
around about a dead guy.
I mean, Taft was the only person
in American history
to ever serve as
president and chief justice,
and yet all anyone knows
about him
is a fake story that sounds like
a plot line from "Family Guy."
"Oh, Lois, it happened again.
Get the jaws of life."
[ Laughter ]
"Raymond?"
"No!"
[ Laughter ]
"Peter!"
And that's why there was a giant
statue of Robert E. Lee
on a horse looming over
the old capital
of the Confederacy in Richmond
for 130 years
because white supremacists and
Confederacy apologists
tried to recast him
as some sort of noble hero,
even though it was known
at the time
by actual Civil War heroes
that Lee was a traitor
who disgraced himself.
Ulysses S. Grant said
the cause Lee fought for
"was, I believe,
one of the worst for which
a people ever fought,
and one for which there was
the least excuse."
And Grant's
the guy who beat Lee.
How the hell did Lee end up with
a giant statue, and not Grant?
If anything, there should have
been a giant statue in Richmond
of Grant kicking Lee
in the balls.
Even better, it could be
a clock that tolls on the hour.
[ Bell tolls ]
[ Laughter ]
Not sure if 1:00 was
the funniest of our options.
[ Laughter ]
Well, yesterday, finally,
after 130 years,
that wretched monument
to an evil cause
was finally taken down,
with a crowd gathering
to celebrate
as Lee was hauled away.
-The nation's largest
Confederate monument
just came down.
The giant Robert E. Lee statue
in Richmond, Virginia,
which is 6 stories tall and
weighs 12 tons,
well, it was just removed.
Shaq, what is the community
saying about this?
What was it like to watch this?
-I'll tell you,
there were celebrations,
there were cheers,
there were chants.
-♪ Na-na-na na,
na-na-na na ♪
♪ Hey, hey, goodbye ♪
-First of all,
as a baseball fan,
I love the crowd taunting him
like he's a Yankees reliever
in Fenway who just got pulled
after coughing up six runs
in the bottom of the eighth.
There should have been
an angry Sox fan there
pouring beer on his head.
Also, as someone who grew up
going to Fenway,
I can attest that Red Sox fans
are unruly, drunk, and
yet surprisingly knowledgeable
about history.
"Hit the showers, Bobby,
and then go take your medicine
at Appomattox!"
Yeah, that's right,
the Yankees are the new Mets
in "Closer Look" punch lines,
gut don't worry,
the Mets blew it
in extra innings last night,
so they're still the Mets.
I don't follow the Mets scores.
I just know what happened
because as I was leaving
last night,
the entire crew was sitting
in a circle,
sobbing and hugging each other,
and saying,
"We don't deserve this,"
which just between us,
some of them do.
[ Laughter ]
Second, there's
nothing more humiliating
than being carried away
on a horse, in the air.
When you're sitting astride
a horse on the ground,
you look like a noble hero,
but when you're sitting
on one in the sky,
getting lifted up by a crane,
you look like
a Porta-Potty getting hauled
away after Burning Man
or a guy who glued himself
to his horse
and now can't get
out the front door.
"Oh, it happened again."
"Raymond?"
[ Laughter ]
Anyone who loves America
should be watching this scene
and celebrating
along with the crowd.
A monument to a traitor
who fought for an evil cause --
the cause of slavery --
white supremacy,
and who tried to destroy
the United States
finally has been taken down,
but you'll never guess
who had a slightly different
take on things.
-Former President Donald Trump
issued a statement
calling the removal a, quote,
"complete desecration"
and lamenting that Lee
was not available
to lead the United States
in Afghanistan.
-Trump said in a statement,
quote, "If only we had
Robert E. Lee
to command our troops
in Afghanistan,
that disaster would have ended
in a complete and total victory
many years ago.
What an embarrassment
we are suffering
because we don't have
the genius of a Robert E. Lee!"
-First of all, dingus,
you're from Queens.
It's pretty hard to remake
yourself as a good old boy
when you sound like
a super in Astoria.
"You know what this [Bleep]
apartment needs?
Some freakin' magnolias.
Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, what do you mean
it would have ended in victory
if Lee was in charge?
He lost.
He's famous for losing.
But, ah, yes,
if only Robert E. Lee had been
in charge in Afghanistan,
then surely he would have said
something inspirational,
like, "Is that a missile?!
All I have is a bayonet,
and I'm glued to my horse!
Get me out of here!"
Trump also called it
"a beautiful piece
of bronze sculpture."
And if Trump ever calls anything
beautiful,
you know it's the opposite.
Look at his apartment.
It looks like the set of an '80s
game show called "Gold Rush."
Of course, I wouldn't recommend
taking history lessons
from a guy who,
among other things,
praised Nazis,
sowed an insurrection
where rioters carried
the Confederate flag,
thought Frederick Douglass
was still alive,
didn't know why the Civil War
happened in the first place,
and thought there were airports
during the Revolutionary War.
-The Continental Army suffered a
bitter winter of Valley Forge,
found glory across the waters
of the Delaware,
and seized victory
from Cornwallis of Yorktown.
Our Army manned the airports --
rammed the ramparts,
it took over the airports,
it did everything it had to do.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
Who can forget
the infamous
Battle of LaGuardia,
where Patrick Henry
famously said,
"Give me priority boarding
or give me death"?
"He's why the peanuts
are free now.
Used to have to pay
for the peanuts."
To this day, schoolchildren
still take trips
to the Buffalo Wild Wings
in Terminal D,
where Washington's army
camped out during the winter.
And we all remember the words
of British general
Charles Cornwallis,
who upon surrendering, said, "We
just want to leave LaGuardia.
Where is ground transportation?
The signs are very confusing."
This is the guy the Republican
Party has made its leader --
the guy they've lined up behind,
a guy who sowed an insurrection
to overthrow democracy,
oversaw the preventable death
of hundreds of thousands
of people,
and praised
traitors and racists.
That's why he and his loyalists
need to be thoroughly banished
from our institutions and
shunned from our politics.
And yesterday
the Biden administration
took another small step toward
accomplishing that goal.
-Months into
Joe Biden's presidency,
his administration is still
cleaning house
as it relates to
former Trump officials,
with the director
of the White House's
presidential personnel office
sending letters to 18 people
on three different
government advisory boards,
asking them to resign.
-Familiar names include
White House counselor
Kellyanne Conway
to the Air Force Academy,
and former press secretary
Sean Spicer
to the Naval Academy.
-Why were there still any
Trump holdovers anyway?
That's like moving into
a rent-controlled apartment
the last guy died in,
and keeping
all the expired whitefish
in the refrigerator.
And why was Kellyanne Conway
on an Air Force advisory board?
If she ever flew an F-16 or what
she probably calls an F-17,
guessing it would end up
in a ravine,
with her standing on the tarmac
in a parachute,
claiming it was
a successful landing.
"The plane is on the ground.
Do you not think the plane
is on the ground?"
But my favorite part
of this little episode was
the reaction from former Trump
press secretary Sean Spicer,
a commander in the
U.S. Naval Reserve
who apparently has his own show
on Newsmax now.
Spicer was outraged by the
explanation for his removal
given know by current White
House press secretary Jen Psaki.
First, let's see Psaki's answer.
-Well, I will let others
evaluate
whether they think
Kellyanne Conway and Sean Spicer
and others were qualified
or not political
to serve on these boards,
but the president's
qualification requirements
are not your party registration.
They are whether you're
qualified to serve
and whether you're aligned
with the values
of this administration.
-Okay, you can
agree or disagree,
but seems perfectly calm,
perfectly reasonable.
Now let's check in
on how Spicer's doing.
-I'm announcing tonight,
for the first time,
that I will not
be submitting my resignation,
and I will be joining a lawsuit
to fight this.
Maybe it's because they want to
inject liberal ideology,
like critical race theory
into the curriculum
and they want to ensure
there's no pushback
and zero oversight.
Each of us chooses how we're
going to serve this country.
I won't ever question
how anyone chooses to do that.
I won't question how you choose
to do that, Jen,
but don't you dare ever
minimize or question
my service to this nation.
You got it?
-"And if you're wondering
why it's so echoey,
I shoot this show in a cave!"
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so, you're filing a lawsuit?
Who are you gonna get
to represent you?
"Sean, I'm gonna be late
for the hearing.
I was trimming my nose hair
at the Cinnabon at LaGuardia.
Yeah.
At the Paul Revere ride."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it happened
a few weeks ago.
Who cares? It's Rudy.
There's no
statute of limitations
on crazy Rudy, especially
because Rudy doesn't even know
when a statute of
limitations is.
"A statute of limitations?
I thought they took that down."
A monument to a traitor
who fought for slavery
and white supremacy
was finally torn down,
should have never been there
in the first place,
and yet there's
a political movement
in this country
that, to this day,
still reveres and apologizes
for traitors
who fought for
an evil Confederacy.
We need to make sure
these people never get
near power ever again, period.
-You got it?
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.